oh
[Applause]
Monday Friday happy Friday everybody I
said Monday oh the drinking has started
first let's welcome tonight's guests he
knows thoughtful Pros like I know extra
toes
novelist and literary critic Walter Kerr
she's so Southern she sleeps in a deep
fryer co-host of the bottom line
launching January 23rd on Fox News
egg in the doll
she's the girl of your dreams if you
have a 104 fever
excuse contributor
and finally the Great Barrier Reef is
his loofah my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion
all right so before we get to some news
stories get all over the document
Scandal it's time for this
Greg's leftovers
oh I love this it's leftovers where I
read the jokes we didn't use this week
and as always it's my first time reading
them so they aren't funny don't blame me
I checked out months ago
here we go convicted sex trafficker GIS
Lane Maxwell is reportedly teaching
etiquette classes to her fellow inmates
that's not even the punch line lessons
include table manners formal greetings
and folding a bed sheet with your neck
foreign
it's never polite to ask a teenager how
old she is
Microsoft's new AI tool only needs to
hear three seconds of your voice to
mimic you making it the only thing on
Earth that can do it faster than your
angry wife
that's the stock photo that we found to
explain marriage
stock photos are great
earlier this week an Amtrak train got
stuck in South Carolina and took over 36
hours to get to Florida usually to get
stranded that long you'd have to fly
Southwest
oh
in his new book Prince Harry revealed
that he once got frostbite on his penis
during a trip to the North Pole
but luckily his balls were safe in a jar
in his wife's purse
aids to President Biden have discovered
classified documents in his possession
Biden since apologized saying he saw the
words top secret and thought it was the
KFC recipe
a professor at Penn State University is
claiming that straight people can learn
to be bisexual simply by watching gay
porn but my roommate Scott and I already
knew that
I should read these
in Massachusetts this week Ben Affleck
was spotted serving people at a Dunkin
Donuts drive through
said Affleck it's always nice to
disappoint customers with something
besides my acting
six journalists in South Sudan were
arrested this week over the circulation
of footage appearing to show president
salvakir wetting his pants
but they were later released and told if
they can keep quiet about an incontinent
president they'll have a job at CNN
yeah a smattering it's a smattering
the South Carolina veteran took down a
knife-wielding man at a Walmart last
Wednesday no Shoppers were stabbed
although several did die from obesity
that seemed kind of low
out of left field and funny
a father in Ecuador has legally changed
his gender to improve his chances in a
custody case if he wins he promises to
sue himself for child support
and finally for the first time in his
presidency Joe Biden visited the border
in El Paso this week when asked what the
most memorable part of the trip was he
said well obviously it was when I said
Mr Gorbachev tear down this wall
[Laughter]
all right
let's do some news
he he left files by the Corvette and
like his pants the excuses are all wet
a special counsel aren't they all has
been appointed to investigate how top
secret classified documents ended up in
President Biden's Delaware garage and an
office he used in Washington DC and a
third batch at his residence in
Wilmington it's true you can now find
classified documents wherever balance of
nature is sold
trying to get a sponsor deal
it's shocking usually when Joe leaves
something behind it's cleaned up with a
carpet steamer
a lot of poop jokes but it could be an
honest mistake after all Joe left behind
a lot more in Afghanistan like weapons
and people but according to what
Democrat congressman from Georgia
something much more nefarious is afoot
I'm suspicious of the timing of it I'm
I'm also aware of the fact that things
can be planted on people things can be
planted in places and then discovered
conveniently it's an interesting Theory
almost as interesting as Guam tipping
over into the ocean
my fear is that the whole island will
become so overly populated that it will
tip over and uh and capsize
it's a classic and I love that man so
he's actually suggesting someone planted
the documents to frame the president
seems pretty hard to believe concerning
Biden's garage was locked
but let's be honest if Biden is Being
Framed we know who had the opportunity
and motive
[Applause]
but you know who the real winners are in
all of this Chinese spies
who can now get top secret files at
garage sales
before they had to bang Eric swalwell
Walter uh great to see you uh I was I I
can't wait to hear your opinions I love
this story it's like it's the best story
it's the best karmic story of the year
so this early year don't you think
well I I think the meaning of this story
is that the Democratic party has decided
it's time to lock Joe Biden in a garage
yes
um
and it's probably a good idea he's he's
a lot like a vintage Corvette Joe Biden
um
he's kind of nostalgic to look at but if
you take it out and drive it uh it might
break down and you can't get parts
[Laughter]
also like a vintage Corvette in that he
doesn't meet modern Mission standards
all right
no catalytic converter a lot of noxious
tailpipe emissions
but you know the other thing I keep
thinking is why are there documents in
the garage isn't everything on a
computer these days I mean the only
documents left are like marriage
licenses the Declaration of Independence
so what's in there like the Magna Carta
or uh yeah exactly this is kind of it to
use a bit of your metaphor if this is a
plot by the Democrats which it might be
to get them out it's like they're trying
to get the car keys from Gramps that's
what they're trying to do ramps canola
what or if it was a plot by the
Democrats it could be because they want
Trump to look good because they think
that Trump would be easier to beat than
somebody like Ron DeSantis I'm just
saying if we're doing conspiracies let's
get more creative yeah that's a good one
that is a good one boy that's a lot of
work though and the last time the last
time I don't think that's what happened
yeah they tried that before and he got
elected yes no they did
but they did they absolutely did that
already but they feel they still feel so
comfortable running against them they
don't have much else but they're still
doing the yeah well look at how bad
Trump is thing all these years later
they still are doing that yeah it's
amazing you know Dagan I love that this
is like a karmic implosion of the
avenatti scale right remember avenatti
was on the uh like he
why Biden reminds me of that is they
both were self-righteous blowhards about
a specific thing right and that specific
thing has hoisted them on their own
batard
and I don't even know what a petard is
but I'd like to be hoisted on one if you
know what I mean
you would yeah voice me on your petard
hoist me I say
I do have a lot of ropes and pulleys at
home but
um I won't say that word because if I
say it in southern it's going to get me
into trouble right
um I I'm not going to talk about
avenatti but I do understand people
women who carry grudges as I have a lot
of like little homemade dolls in my
apartment of people I put hexes on
purses you know little old pantyhose
stuffed with uh cotton balls never mind
um
I I think this is a woman
I'm I'm gonna travel down tyrus's road
because if you want to get back at a man
you go after his car um
and you go in the garage with the
Stiletto
and you go after the tires on the vet
and while you're in the garage
shiv in the tires you're gonna plant
some extra documents to you know to make
sure the think tank documents in DC are
not a one-off and just thinking out of
the box it's definitely Kamala Harris
you got it you you have to realize that
if you listen to her I was the Attorney
General of California I was a U.S
senator and in the last two years you've
had me talking about space with some
kitty actors and being a greeter for
dead fish in the Philippines yeah and
now you've decided you old jackass
codger that you're running again you got
to get rid of them you know the awesome
you really want to go after a man what
you do is you get with his dad and then
you make him call you his stepmom
that's interesting you know I thought uh
Tyrus that uh she's getting back hold on
hold on wait a minute let's
see
I was like should I say it and it was
too late yeah because I I had that would
hurt right when you said petard I had
thought something else so I can't say it
but
um remember he was the guy that hurt
that little girl remember on the debate
I was that little girl you put on yeah
put him on a bus yes but I was that
little girl but she loves buses so it's
like confusing electric bus because it
would make sense like he put me on the
bus so I'm gonna put him on the bus yeah
out of DC exactly you know she couldn't
say that because that sounded cool but
my favorite part of this whole thing is
they still blamed all this on the Trump
Administration right because they made
it weird when they're transitioning and
that's why we took all the documents
with us because there was no one to give
it to like that's literally what they're
what they're going with which makes zero
sense listen it's kamala's people
probably jumped on this but this is what
happens when you let your kids put your
stuff away they just put it anywhere
that is true he gave Hunter had one job
to do
one thing take all the documents that
connect me to you and get rid of them
yes and you know what he did and he hit
him at the places where he would never
go a library dad's garage and home yes
classic son yeah
one job
one job yeah Cat last word to you has
this been a great week for for for I
guess I don't know Justice no cause
nothing's gonna happen I mean it's just
with people in power know that they're
afforded special treatment and then they
behave in a way that reflects that so
typical week a typical week all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else